[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
there's one minute
[Music]
ah welcome
new stream yeah
how y'all doing this lovely sunday
very nice
not late one second
sponsored stream by by mutant very
exciting
uh it's available pre-order may 25th
they reached out to me because they
thought i'd like the game which is
really cool i'm actually really excited
about this
uh so if you wanna if you like what you
see
uh check it out support uh epic games
that support epic channel
jack told me about this game it's been
in uh developing a while
he said he saw it at pax a couple years
ago i don't know
so he said it look cool hold up i forgot
to charge my
but without further ado
let's go they said going blind
or that it's cool to if i do that
because uh that's where it could shine
i'm excited what does that mean i have
no idea what to expect
is that too loud no
here we go bio mutant
oh you know it's a a swedish dev
because it has a b every company has
that and i don't know why
thank you
oh
uh-huh should have checked this out
let's check for uh
subtitles on we're good gucci my gamers
easy medium or hard always hard
i'm a pro gamer everyone knows this
let me know if the audio is too low or
too high
so cute and evil looking at the same
time oh
what i get to change him awesome oh
dumb done no thanks
okay you know that's cool fip
looks like a proper weasel linny okay
they have different skills as well cool
don't alterate too much
i'm surprised oh dum-dum has the higher
no lower intellect
oh bless kind of makes me want to play
as dumb done
my voice is too high okay here we go
dumb dumb middies
uh the funny character starting
attributes okay to see more detailed
explanation of what uh-huh
define your genetic structure
oh you don't like dumb dumb don't hate
him dumb them how dare you
he's just been conceived i can randomize
it
[Music]
big brain huge brain
but so strong oh
this is trippy dude
ah what do we want
oh cool there's a different genetic code
for each one
so small brain but why brain large when
body's strong right
i feel like dum-dum should be living up
to his name right
thick boy thick as hell
dum-dum don't look so dumb anymore huh
hey i like it
charisma he doesn't need charisma oh god
i have to pick one
it says details okay defines your amount
of health and energy of course dodging
amount of health okay armor uh-huh
yeah uh-huh what is intellect then key
energy uh how fast your key energy
regenerates
defines amount of moves you can perform
while trying to com play
puzzles oh no
maybe i should compensate for my lack of
intellect
i feel like this looks the dumbest so
maybe that's what we should go for
no pp genetics yeah
i don't want to say i'm disappointed but
oh
well i don't know
uh what do we hate dum dum hates
the heat
and bio sure choose your first style
what oh okay
which one looks the ugliest i'm not sure
i can't quite like this one pick your
main color
oh dumb dumb can change so much
cool
guess we go with the red fit our orange
right kind of looks good already i like
that
choose your detail color oh my gosh oh
okay black can i
oh dumb
pewdiepie skillful rock was choosing the
life of
trained as an operative of an elite
special operation jesus
okay oh that's dub
[ __ ] there's a lot more to it than i
thought okay
that's kind of cool he's get it's a
jacket
sentinel what the [ __ ]
looks like a sloth all of a sudden
saboteur
uh dodging your route okay
i don't know
oh you can't see all of it my bad gamers
dead eye that's kind of cool though
commander they're all cool
quite like saboteur melee dual wield
skill
equip two different one-handed oh
quite like let's go saboteur he gets a
jacket and jeans what else do you want
right
are we ready are we happy with this i
think yes
it it will work uh-huh here's somebody
nice fast drawn into the spotlight of a
story that's already begun
okay nice
we're already at the crossroads exactly
is that fork in the road where you make
a choice
or simply stop living
thank you bye mutant for using youtube
friendly words i appreciate that
it's not only a crossroad but a choice
a reflection of your key the primal
energy that flows through
everything well i'm dark red
yeah obviously
allow me to introduce myself i'm the
dark side of you your inner voice to be
precise
an echo of the balance and consequence
of your actions as you move
forward
i'm definitely one with the darkness
can't believe you'd choose that
thing over me but i'll be here
i'm edgy sure not gonna happen
that thing i'm right here let me remind
you we're two halves of the same
with the difference being i'm the better
half yeah that's why i picked it
better half my way is both better and
brighter
light makes it easier to see the best
end
[ __ ] she has a point the best end is the
one you decide yourself
and it seems we're headed in the right
direction yeah yeah
the [ __ ] up light okay
was it just trash laying around alright
somewhat dark must get darker mr dum dum
is ready for his adventure
interesting scenery here all right
what's left can be right
sometimes haha trick to game i'm going
right right
is always right i had i did the fake
rooney
where i went left and then okay
oh oh whoa we have a gun dum-dum has a
gun
okay i'm ready dun dun's ready
stories of death from the bodies left
behind
a reminder that we're at the mercy of
nature
is that a unicorn
everything is so weird i don't know what
to expect
what the [ __ ] is this the beast that
shattered your family
or did you choose to forget i turned
your back on
our world and got lost in your own
meanwhile the predator only grew
stronger
[Music]
it's a [ __ ] unicorn mate give him a
bottle of water
sheep oh looper loopy ah
i was just asking how do i roll
no problem
monkey wheel whoa that's so cool
click click click reload then
whoa
hold up phoenix flight
panthers sweet i don't think i want to
do that right now
oh hell yeah
viper bite
oh [ __ ] yeah
reload
no problem there we go
is he dead
dodge [ __ ] i'm stuck in a palm tree
whoa i even do that
okay sorry it's a tutorial i completely
forgot
there we go do the thing that it says
felix my bad
do the tutorial please sorry you better
make a run for it
no this to end this story oh no
okay that's fine i can run
[Music]
bye
i wanted to try out the things they're
so cool
nice see pro gamer right there most
people would probably have failed on the
tutorial
this time it was best to run and live to
fight another day
let us hope you're ready for it when it
comes
what the hell is gonna bunker
whoa i got knuckles
flanky stabby
yeah it looks great it runs great too i
don't know if it shows up for you guys
yeah the predator isn't the only threat
the wildlife started to mutate when the
end of days began
and the tree of life started to die
discord mod breeding factory we found it
at last
move towards an enemy target them with
melee attacks aim the camera towards an
enemy to target them with range attack
reload your ranged weapons key energy is
used for dodging using mutations and
performing special attacks when you're
out of key energy you'll
be unable to form these actions your key
energy regenerates both in and out of
combat okay
okay
shoot it's so [ __ ] cool
dope as hell dude
oh dodge that [ __ ]
[ __ ] their level one monster so i just
realized
get the [ __ ] outta here oh no it's gonna
kill me
oh wait yeah [ __ ] you
beaver thing yeah
i mastered the game already i know
you're all impressed thank you
just gotta check for stuff it's so
deeply ingrained in me after the last
let's play
gotta check for stuff you know why the
hell is that they
huh no stuff all right
i know you're all impressed thank you
hey that's my stop
electric module uh-huh found a weapon
special
effect add-on attach it to your ranged
weapon to give it an extra
damage type for as long as i'm aligned
so many enemies have resistance or
weakness okay
so what is this then electric gotcha
pickup attach special
add-ons select it through the consumable
quick menu
okay
love the posture i have great posture
medic supply
okay they heal me it doesn't
automatically regenerate in combat you
have to use consumables or find other
ways to heal
well your health doesn't okay my bad
oh better hold on to that
i can you can use uh-huh okay
i'm full baby
[Music]
but which way those burn
they do it's not a rope though
hold up what's in here oh don't do it
oh hell yeah it's worth licking around
nice
is my gaming setup floor gang for life
as you can see
check for the ak shut the [ __ ] up come
on
dude i what are these forks called
my favorite turtle had them growing up
as a kid rafael
the ninja forks i was like why does he
have forks that's so cool
i still don't know why to most it only
means death
but some have adapted to the new
environment
with it hell yeah
oh oh all right perry all right
let's try a power of this guy
ow and we're working once
okay all enemies can often be looted for
healing items uh-huh
uh-huh remember that you said huh uh-huh
uh-huh
oh we have two and we got plenty of help
oil that point
okay
should we take a bath
oh oh no oh no
dum dum what did you do dum dum
you dum dum
that's cool it's called twinsigh
now i know hey guys
whoa who threw that
don't do that don't do that don't do
that
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
hold up let me reload shoot it shoot it
shoot it
yeah [ __ ]
nice and slow nice and slow
idiot get [ __ ]
yeah dum-dum no one missed redundant
hey candy i like it
seriously
what do you guys think
up
still don't understand how i use these
but
or are they the ones
no they are the ones okay
gotcha
let's go dumb dumb oh [ __ ] iron wall
the [ __ ]
not a high q game plan oh [ __ ]
reload oh [ __ ]
don't think so [ __ ]
oh iron well too strong is this one of
those where i'm supposed to run
oh [ __ ] wrong one
run iron wall too strong
let's take care of these guys first
whoa
come on come on
yeah now we're talking gotta use that
key
come on
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
it says defeat the iron wall i don't
[ __ ]
[Applause]
i'll do melee then there we go he's weak
oh [ __ ] it's kind of what the [ __ ] is
that
oh easy iron wall
weak it's because i'm so tall
defeating the enemies uh and complaining
because we'll give you xp leveling up
allows you to raise one of your
tributes by 10 you'll also get one point
you can use the unlock skills in the
wong fu
perks menu cool
all right wong fu
oh so beautiful should we try his
intellect
bless you dumb dumb
hmm
we're quite high on agility
[Music]
should i move the camera maybe yeah good
idea hold up one sec
i'll make myself a little smaller as
well
he's a dum-dum
who can fight fight fight
here we go
strength maybe health never hurts to get
hell
start with that
[Music]
quite like the ranged combat
dual will guns would be cool two-faced
cobra
sounds [ __ ] awesome
i think i only have one gun though [ __ ]
uh once you have more upgrade points
remember to spend them
so the saboteur okay he also gains
weapon based ranged attacks from enemies
have 10
chance of missing you 10
that's nothing
maneuvers uh-huh
uh-huh double jump uh-huh
it's good to know i'm curious what the
other ones are to play it like now
we don't have any upgrade points what am
i doing it's
in this section you can change equipment
and weapons
you can start your gear according to
different stats
you can scrap the highlighted piece of
gear for crafting resources okay
we don't have nothing though
i can make different setups oh i like
that
very sexy oh actually
i actually became sexy i didn't mean to
the [ __ ] that i just do
please put it back on you're sabotaging
yourself there we go
nice
put some clothes on hey don't tell me
what they do
look an emergency box from the once was
a new weapon
gordon dum-dum here
is that better
[Music]
[Music]
all right let's keep going i'll use it
in a sec
that pipe looks weak the claw bar should
come in handy [ __ ] i need it okay
i know they just told me
how they [ __ ] the way equipment
why am i looking at you guys so no one
has this game yet
uh
oh i literally press e okay
come on
[ __ ] i can't get help from chat for one
whoa
i'm gonna play a game it's time to find
a way out of this place
no really i mean it
he's lying i know it
we already knew these hell yeah
now i can't stop using it
the morks produce biomatter in their
multi-organ
i can't [ __ ] hear including you
[ __ ]
small it's cool
combat is fun especially when you're
this damn good
yes
a bioblob a bioblob
it's my bioblind thank you
did you drop anyone
give me that just be glad there's a rope
i am thank you it's a chain
i'm sorry bro
can i equip the dual pistols
automation i don't even notice that
little [ __ ]
yeah i got the game early special
swedish privileges
you're watching it first live baby
toxinol
built vessels called arks to save
themselves from the impending doom
but was it too late it is only from the
flight logs of the single arc
they left behind that we know other arcs
traveled through the sky and beyond
it seems those that came before us never
lost hope in finding a new home don't
worry i'll kind of
i'll fix it i'll set it straight don't
worry
oh no wait we're on the dark pad oh
we're gonna [ __ ] it up
[ __ ] them oh god oh no
oh god here we go biggest brain
in the world about to solve this okay to
switch node
then rotate this is the number of
rotation even
left each node certain position must be
rotating complete uh-huh
okay so i rotate this
[Music]
yeah easy [ __ ] wrong way
just a few moves left
thank you thank you i do what i came
there are few records of the chain of
events that led to the big apocalypse
eons ago
and it's clear the world wasn't prepared
for how
recklessly the toxin oil corporation
would make its mark on the world
come on their rare earth mining and
nuclear industries
generated tons of waste without
consideration for the future
they dumped it all in landfills until
they ran out of space
that's what else are they going to
predict mistake
they began dumping the toxic waste in
the surf just off the cur
oh my bad that it would sink and decay
with time
and they were right but no one was
prepared for what was about to unfold
once in the surf the radiation
interfered with the genetics of the
wildlife
and created bizarre mutations in their
offspring
it's just like their netflix movie
deceivable impact on biodiversity and
the entire ecosystem
the world as they knew it crumbled as
nature
retaliated it would never be the same
again
and what remained of it became ours
dum-dum was born glorious dum-dum is it
lagging a little bit
how's the stream look like new stream
dumb dumb
huh it doesn't pick up as many frame
rates
see if i can fix that
oh it's on 30 fps ew
ew hold up can i restart it
maybe i'll do it later
sound of spark metal going pew pew is
never
a good thing it's coming from behind
that door
a warning label the box looks like a
potential brain melt
that doesn't take much for me
or dumb dumb it's going to take a bit of
puzzling to short-circuit the door
i think i can do this one uh-huh uh-huh
i mean dum-dum doesn't get enough credit
i really think there you go
come on dumb get it oh no what is this
no i'm not doing that
i cannot air strike a man in a
wheelchair
the wheeled one is outnumbered you'd
better help him oh thank god
i thought oh [ __ ]
i was like where the [ __ ] will help him
obviously
ah [ __ ]
how dare you pick on the wii
yeah thanks for not counseling me by me
i appreciate it
come on whoa that was cool i didn't know
i could do that
ow shut down let me try that again
yeah knee slide baby
that's the last of them let's talk to
the wheeled one before backup arrives
i'm in a wheelchair please abstract me
don't say that
there we go we got some clink and plank
all we need all you need in life
there's a rope here bro
gotta check the rope though too early
for rope
i'm still wondering what if i took the
right turn
he wants to thank you for taking his
side against the scavengers
he sounds familiar you just can't figure
out
why he presents himself as
out of date he knows he's way overdue
but he hasn't given up
i respect that he doesn't seem surprised
that you don't recognize him you were
just a child
back then the night everything changed
when fire nation behind me rumors of a
one-eyed ronin seen outside the great
wall
and he's happy to see it's true
the legend of the one-eyed child that
grew up as an
outcast is old and sad
the child could have been anyone but the
evil it had fled had left a mark a
facial scar
to remember the past i want a scar
it's a scar you're covering under that
eye patch isn't it
but he would have recognized you anyways
you look exactly like your mumma
okay there's no doubt you're the child
and that what
looper lupine did to your village
[ __ ] looper looping
haters the beginning of the end
he says it has taken you a long time to
bring the past back
up to the present to find your way back
but he's grateful you have
oh god it was after the attack
that the unity fell apart your mum's
disciples divided
and formed tribes as a reaction to the
blight
that had fallen upon the land
am i making all the right choices
the impending threat of the world eaters
bringing down the tree of life is
ever so close he also worries about the
jagne tribe
that's actively working for a doomsday
and
purging of the world that's a long
translation
no one would have survived he hopes you
at least
remember the tree he goes
uh by default dialogues are set to dance
from one mpc line to the next
automatically if you want to manually
advance the dialogue you can change this
okay ah
dumb dumb as a little child with this
little
hat so cute
let's go down them ah dum-dums puppy
is it you no [ __ ] now
asks if you were tired as it's a bit of
a hike here from the village
he wonders if your mumma knows you are
here
i hope i told her
you're such a good child so you probably
did
even the young forget true he
understands why you came all the way out
here
to see them the potato people you know
what
[Music]
the potato people yeah are a
wonder somehow interlinked with this
little tree here
fueling its source of life
prefer potato people obviously
you might be right like potatoes they're
packed with energy
an excellent source of key oh the nano
prefer to hide in glitter grass we're
gonna fight him or not
you should get over there and ruffle it
see if you can make one
come out of hiding
[Music]
ruffle the glitter glass grass is
jackson the chain
every time i see chad saying that i
never seen
he's like a mystical being of this
channel
like the potato people oh my god oh i
get it now [ __ ] hell
all right wait where's the [ __ ] grass
i'm so dumb
ah yes can we jump from here
perfect
you guys think you're so funny don't you
all right let's
rustle in come out jacksepticeye
you leprechaun son of a [ __ ]
you found one you should be proud they
don't come out for everyone
thank you
the nano's key energy is just what the
pension needs to complete its cycle
and grow into a tree of life
okay but will it grow strong in that
only time will tell at least his
intention is to dedicate his
life to it he has the feeling the fate
of the world
depends on it no you need to support the
tree for a long time to come
the only way it will grow tall is with
the burst of
ki released
[Music]
i'm so small and pathetic all right is
that an actual [ __ ] potato what am i
looking at here
oh my god dude come here
come here oh you pathetic
you handle that net like you've never
done anything else
thank you thank you
he's grateful for all the help he can
get there's lots of nano out there that
need to be guided to the roots of the
pensa tree
uh sure where can i find them
they're hiding in the glitter grass that
mostly grows deep inside
damp caves where they draw mineral from
the natural rock
one day he hopes the tree will have
grown tall enough to sustain the world
but today your focus is getting this one
to become one
with the tree i can do that
why is
[Music]
like elvis presley looking giant dude as
a weasel or whatever he is
wearing jeans telling me about the tree
of life
i'm so confused i have so many questions
all right merge the nono with the tree
got it
it's happening inoscillated pensai
of course
[Music]
now that you've seen the nano's
connection with the tree with your own
eyes
you have no reason to doubt okay from
this day on
he'll make nurturing the pencil into a
tree of life
a life goal not only for our village's
sake
but for all of us everyone
one day the land won't be as peaceful
not even your mumma not even moment get
out of here you can already see the
effects from how reckless those before
us acted
and unless something changes we're
doomed the land won't survive the side
effects of the old world's industrial
[Music]
advances
he says you'd better hurry back to the
village before your mumma comes looking
for you
you did good here today she only cares
about wongfu okay i
shouldn't make her worry
no she's got lots on her mind and needs
rest after the raid last night on the
looping camp with her disciples
wonders if they let the predator family
live or not
[Music]
he says he remembers every single day he
devoted to growing the tree of life
but now he's afraid it might be in vain
the tree started to die when the end of
days began
and it wasn't long after that that the
world eaters arrived what do we want to
know and the days are worldly
world leaders
the genetic evolution that occurred
after the apocalypse
the toxinol corporation inflicted on the
land
set the world eater's dna into overdrive
[Music]
you think it's the same guy i don't
think so
his friend gizmo is working on a
mcdonald needs help defeating the jumbo
puff at the end of the west
if you ever had that hairstyle you never
let go of it
whiz is still repairing his octopod to
confront the merc puff that dwells deep
down
under the surface of the end of the
northwest route
noco has tamed the majority and is
preparing to take on the hoof puff
what the [ __ ] are all his names
finally goop is almost done with the goo
glide
of course machine able to ride the waves
of the surf
all the way out to the porchy puff at
the end of the route to the southeast
it's all connected baby the tree of life
is holding up
but the question is for how long you're
running out of time
huh okay
seems fine though yeah friends are
gearing up to stop the world eaters
there's one at the end of each route
those [ __ ]
road ahead won't be easy but he's
counting on your support
his friends aren't strong enough to end
this on their own
he wants you to understand that you'll
all die
if the tree isn't saved
[Music]
uh
that's fine i'll save them all okay so i
just got a message apparently i'm
playing on a build from mars
friends have prepared something specific
for each world eater
the mekton the octopod the majute and
the goo glide are almost ready to ride
so it will run better on may 25th in the
tribe
and the situation with the world it's
not that i've noticed anything but
apparently
can i can i get your chair bruh please
why did you let go of that haircut my
dude oh bless him look at him
why oh he looks so sad and pathetic
oh so sad oh
oh
he's living large here in this little
corner
strong enough to climb oh now it does
i see how it is
okay a scale
know that the tree of life is dying its
days are numbered
without help oh it even says in the
corner march i shouldn't have checked
and assault from the world eaters
hey
that's the title screen
[Music]
nice
whoa what dum dum
[Music]
a signpost maps it out for the
cartographically
challenged that's me thank you
[Music]
no no stop it that is not what i would
okay signposts are found near locations
i mean just all around the world you'll
unlock a signpost
when interacting with it uh you can fast
travel okay nice
you can open them out uh-huh
okay i don't think i need to do any of
this
oh that's not a healthy color my dude
you gotta drink more water
[ __ ] sake come on
oh [ __ ]
that must be the world eater that chewed
off out of dates leg
you'll need a hat trick to bring that
down um
well the village is done
did the village drop any loot
that's my way point
look a survivor glad to see someone made
it out alive
oh how cute and pathetic
he's heard the stories about the terror
inflicted by the world eaters to other
enclaves but never expected one to come
all the way here
dude are we missing our bottom jaw i
just realized your inner balance is two
halves that
complete a wholeness that flows through
all things at times
you'll be able to manifest your inner
balance through deeds and dialogue
choices
few of those who always act in the same
matter and a whole
and our wholeness is the sum of the
choices we make in the actions we take
okay the balance of your actions creates
your aura score which
affects the dialogue with other
characters okay be much left to save if
this continues
even if the tree of life survives the
attack
he doesn't know what your connection is
to this place but
something tells him you've stayed true
to your heart
interacting with the uh captives and
side shrines
will award you with side points that you
can use to unlock psionic powers
powers can only be unlocked once you
have reached the required dark or light
balance
anyway he needs help and says it's by
your
side sorry you're not understand why
you'd do such a thing because i picked
the dark pad
well that's not my problem i'm sorry i
picked the dark fat
i didn't need to punch him
i always liked the darkness seriously
i always thought better of you than that
and you were wrong
there's always more dark than light
there's still time to turn back
they're already heading down my road
yeah
[Music]
i didn't think it would punch him
hey we get side points yeah
i'll punch the dude for a side points
come on i'll punch a puppy
there's out of date again i must have
missed something important
out of date knows you'll make a better
stand against the world eaters with the
support of a tribe
and there's two nearby the japanese
tribe is likely to be your primary
choice as they seek to become
omnipresent and most importantly feared
regardless of who you choose it won't be
easy
as the conflict between the tribes is
worse than ever
did he die drink of war no he didn't die
he didn't die did he a little punch come
on
conviction to stop the world eaters
began when the leviathans rose from the
depths of the surf
siding with the myriad's movement for
wholeness in a fragmented world
might seem like the logical thing to do
but is it the right thing
i'm tipping certain though destiny
arrives
all the same i'm too dark i'm too deep
down too deep in the dark side guys
there's no way for me to turn back
we ever had one conviction to bring
balance to the world by wiping out the
weak
they believe a cleansing is necessary to
restore the world
and want to let the world eaters bring
down the tree of life
but siding with chutney isn't
necessarily a bad thing
fate will find a way no no no i'm i've
committed too many crimes
there's no recovery break the stalemate
and shift the balance of power to either
jagnes or myriad's side
he believes the tribe sifus jagni
especially
will listen to you and expects you to
pay at least one of them a visit
and play your part okay
in japanese case letting the world
eaters bring down the tree of life is
part of their plan
they believe a cleansing is the only way
the world can be saved
he'll be waiting for you beneath the
tree of life if you lose track of what
you need to do
regardless you'll meet again once you've
played your part in the tribe war
and the situation with the world eaters
[Music]
pretty cool they let you play as xqc
good one
okay uh we're going we're going here
yeah
yeah another fork in the road
it's either the tunnel or the motor
bridge what'll it be
ah moto bridge i think looks cool
we're going down the fork with our forks
yeah bridge just get over it
there was another path right yeah let's
go this way i don't know i just feel
like it
you could go either way so i mean
natural tunnels like this still
exist most of them got flooded
here we go
should we kill them
hell yeah we should kill them ow
ow [ __ ] i took so much damage
hey can't hit me [ __ ]
one more baby
perfect aim
hell yeah
i knew we picked the right path i look
at my dark
ninjas they're on my side wow
wait is this the myriad sifu i want to
talk to the jag nad
oh that means i have to go the other way
oh my bad my back we gotta go this
way
[ __ ] i'm talking to the jagnat obviously
yeah i created my own character it's
beautiful his name is dum-dum
say no problem is he alright
did i punch where is he where is he
where did he go
he's not dead he's in line he's alive
and living well
all right let's do this
but first let me check out my
love a lot
i'm all right you lady i don't know
strength you've been working out
oh thank you go to the mutation tab to
unlock psi powers okay
[Music]
use blink press down the input you have
bound your ability to it will
teleport you in direction creating a
shock wave
i like blink
uh to use blink press down the input you
have bound your ability to
it will uh
choose an ability to press the button
it's bound to while pressing
and holding middle mouse button
not sure i understand
[Music]
so like
[Music]
okay
oh no i'm helping the bad ones
which ones am i helping okay good
okay let's try the special attack
get [ __ ] get [ __ ]
he keeps doing it he can't keep getting
away with it
how is he so strong
you just fall off the mat
wow wow
foreign
okay jack nag
let's go very pretty destroyed this area
muddied up what used to be muck never
heard that word before
what the [ __ ]
i have never used a health pack what the
[ __ ] is my help
am i almost dying
that's the jagni tribe's fault their
friendship can be a blessing or a curse
it's up to you
you're either a part of their solution
to the tribe war
or part of the problem oh we got to do
it to him
here we go pre-break actually i got a p
break that's perfect
let's see
okay
bb break done i know i'm fast yes i wash
my hands thank you let's keep going
did i pee i didn't pee let's see
i didn't pee
we're going to jag me excuse me can i
take a piss that's not a pee
let's see i'm so sad
okay no pee says they're
wary of strangers they're at war
come on give me a chance i'm so charming
doesn't know if the sifu will have time
for you but
he'll let you in to find out i told you
you can't say no to
i can't say no to this face
i missed an animation oh i already peed
okay thank god
okay good glad we solved that mystery
feared they want to vanquish the tribes
as the only way they can guarantee
peace is through supremacy
okay i'm on board the sifu is determined
to let the world eaters destroy the tree
of life
as it's part of their strategy to
cleanse the world
and start anew
[Applause]
he welcomes you to the jagne fort and
introduces himself as the tribe's sifu
the news of a cold-blooded ronin
crossing the great wall through the
crack in bunker 101 preceded you
that's right
the wall that separates them from the
other side the wasteland you came from
he guesses the time spent there just
left a blank space in your memory
as empty and barren as the wasteland
itself
he understands that sometimes we need to
lose ourselves
to find ourselves but he's glad you
chose to come here
there's something about your spirit that
sparks memories of you was a kiddling
he can still sense your kind-hearted no
oh oh really
okay let's see now i punched it
sometimes one memory can make another
come to life
he hasn't thought about your muma for
ages
even though she taught him a lot he was
one of the original
wong fu disciples sorry moma is not my
mom
that's my uh-huh
oh originally it was based on unarmed
combat and the six weapons
the boomerang the shuriken the bow
the staff the nanchok and the hook and
chain
what about the porsche who says it's
time to set the path
aside at least for now unrest is
sweeping the land and there are rivals
in
all directions jackny doesn't want a new
unity between the tribes
their goal is to become omnipresent and
most importantly
feared
says fear and hatred is the only path to
domination but you already know that
yeah embracing that side of you and
helping them
vanquish yeah i mean and letting the
world eaters destroy the tree
oh yeah yeah i mean
he expected you to join them you
understand that the universe runs on the
principle that the one who dominates
others runs the show
couldn't i put it better myself the sifu
was waiting for something to tip the
balance in their favor
and with you by their side what's the
matter confident you can
vanquish the other tribes all of them
the myriad are too good to be true they
might believe in the greater good and a
code of
honor saving the tree of life
won't change anything you must stop
living in the past
handshake oh
that's not how i would have done it but
you know
they're kin okay let's [ __ ] them up
they have no intention of letting this
drag out or they'll run the risk of
teaching the enemy their art of war
wants you to focus these are the new
rival outposts your tribe needs
templeton
full of oh cool okay
papalito hell yeah
whoa says you'll regret not being on
their side
ah get out of here the only way you
learn their secrets
and the tribe weapon now is if you
defeat him
and that will never happen yeah we'll
see about that you
should take a little [ __ ] come on we
want to wage a war
a war where all that's left behind
is casualties nice i'm excited for work
to be afraid
your fate cannot be taken from you
claim the rival outposts and earn the
right
to wield the tribe weapon
once you've conquered the rivals
outposts you'll challenge
their sifu for control of their
territory
what's the tribe weapon then
brings back his memories of the old
village
jackne doesn't want a new unity between
the tribes
their goal is to become omnipresent he
remembers you
it's always the little things you
remember and with you it's pretty much
the only thing
okay let's [ __ ] him up
i'm ready oh whoa look at this
what up fellas
bye all right dark side
embrace oh cool
[Music]
so we went ahead how did we get there
just walk all right
should i be looking for something
that's gotta be it yeah
this it's a furry yes i'm playing this
game obviously
wonky mumpy
then you're dead mate oh god he's strong
oh god i didn't see it all right let's
go close
he's not so tough up close
i gotta jump over that
sheesh louise
yeah get [ __ ]
oh dodged perfect time dude
i definitely launched come on
okay i'm gonna die if i don't heal
i'm not gonna die at wonky bumpy
stumpy
hey oh he did it twice
that's cheating shoot his knees
there he is level four baby
yeah oh so you get full health when you
level up okay of course
yeah you don't [ __ ] with dumb dumb
hell yeah nice
okay
uh character hmm
charisma seems like it will come useful
but also i'm the dark side
yes they always get by with their charm
don't they
what else have bio points
let's check it out uh
we can get vile bile
oh ew what is phone
oh whoa that's cool i want that maybe
i'll save for that
oh it's the same one but this one isn't
let's save it for now
my childhood village let's burn it down
obligatory task it's uchihara
time
time is i'm ready for this but it evokes
a tingling sensation
there's something special about it
drawing you closer
spp pp time oh yeah
so come to get it let's see
okay but we don't want to fast travel
there
as time passes memories fade oh not the
memories
feelings change it's not about who you
were
it's about who you'll become this story
is far from
over
echoes of a long lost past like whispers
in the wind
ew goop
here's someone who takes each day as it
comes
he asks how you are today
i can't complain i guess why the hell am
i talking about goat
then he wants you to know that if you
find yourself going through bad times
you should just keep going
thanks scoob he wonders where you've
been he hopes you've been out at the
lake
practicing your swimming technique
[Music]
he understands he's not cute get out of
here
only has six disciples doing just one
thing helps you get more done
in less time he thinks you should really
know how to swim by now
why perry the platypus
why not there's no better time to do
what needs to be done than right now is
he a platypus what the [ __ ] is he
ew oh you're kind of thick though not
gonna lie
thanks you can swing the most waters
while in very deep water
you'll slowly lose key okay
oh what a form it's perfect
how dare you goop
he says that wasn't too bad was it
at least i learned how to not swim true
at least you learn oh it's an otter if
you don't swim
but you need practice lots of practice
okay fine i'll keep trying buddy
great things usually happen to those who
never stop crying
he hopes you'll be one of them thanks
for the lesson
you just need more time in the surf
that's the only way you'll ever learn
how to swim
oh i'll try harder to soak up your
instructions
got it you can never try too hard
judging by your mum's look it seems you
forgot something oh that is my moment
you promised you'd train with her before
the sun goes down
it's time to go
okay i'm ready we will learn some new
moves training is important
you can't rely solely on the fact that
wong fu
is in your blood
she'll see you at the village square all
right
[Music]
she'll be waiting for you there will be
a surprise for you at the end
too a surprise my forks
here's another familiar face with lots
on his mind what the hell is this
then asks how you're feeling today
[Music]
uh
is that what he comes up with is
actually useful
smart man
he was hoping you could help him pick up
some scrap for a thingamajig he's
working on
okay i can do that it might be good
he's happy to hear that from someone
that should be evil
of the coming generation you owe it to
yourself to protect them yeah it's very
cute
you should look for things that are
recyclable it shouldn't take you too
long to find some
all right
[Music]
it's new main quest two main quests
what bloody hell i'll find some here
got a tappy
we found one
i love the game's all right that's cool
yeah
[Music]
he wonders what usefulness you found
he says every little thing comes oh
that's sweet
[Music]
he can work wonders with almost anything
and asks if you know how to
upcycle i'm ready
that's the spirit you can't make a
difference unless you get your hands
dirty
he'd love to teach you to upcycle and
the scrap you found would be a good
start
oh okay
uh-huh it's weird how we craft
now though but okay uh the canoe
cartridge select the handle slot
sorry what oh
uh select the handle you want in order
to craft your weapon
uh-huh whoa
oh what oh
whoa there's so many options jesus a
bone
why did why did i do this
[Music]
you did well but he can't help but
wonder why you decided to craft a weapon
honestly i wanted some yeah cutting edge
nice nice he appreciates those able to
deliver a
sharp remark well it's a hammer so
he understands but hopes you won't be
needing it anytime
soon okay i'll teach you more money more
with you
thinks mastering the six weapon styles
of one foo
is more than enough for anyone he's
looking forward to seeing what you'll
make next
it seems you have a talent for this the
possibilities
or you don't like you're like bone
hammer lose her patience
nice bone hammer you know she doesn't
like waiting for you
she wants to see you on the village
square right away
thank you so much appreciate you okay
um yeah what's up
you'll continue to build on the basics
talent will only take you so far
no it looks awful let's get real here
she wants you to grow up and start
thinking for yourself you really need to
find yourself before she's gone
mumma i look like i'm two years old okay
i'll try harder
that's all she's ever asked of you that
you'll try and give it your best
you can't do more than that lava
supporting
and loving moma you've always followed
your own path
but this time she needs you to follow
her
she wants you to understand that
whatever path you choose in life
you must stay true to yourself i've
stayed true to my past so far
thank you very much
all right oh hell yeah this time
is awesome what up gang determined
better watch out
[ __ ] them up
he asks you to stop right there and
wonders where you think you're going
art of war always avoid the fight if you
can
don't want trouble that makes him wonder
why
you were here looking for it there's no
way they'll let you pass
yes you'll die
he wants to know who you think you are
no one needs to get hurt you'll have to
face pain at some point
he offers to help you get it over with
ah oh you're dead you're dead you're
absolutely dead
you're so dead oh bone hammer
tasty oh jesus it's a bit too strong
[ __ ] hell bomb hammer crushes oh oh
no
bone don't touch bone hammer how dare
you
no no i just got it
they took my board over she asks if
you're hurt
what happened they're insecure they're
insecure
yeah if confidence is silent and
insecurity is loud
she thinks you're absolutely right the
most important thing is that you're okay
thanks moma you're the best it's time to
focus on your
[Music]
i'm gonna kill them this is uh this is
my backstory why i became evil
because they took my bone hammer i can't
believe it like i'm a little right dude
here's someone close to heart doing what
he does best
i thought for sure they'd go with pupa
he heard you helped gizmo clean up he's
proud of you
[Music]
he asks if you could help him too before
you leave for training
okay let's make it quick because i want
to fight some we get bone hammer bang
he'll leave the quick part to you you're
the martial artist
after all he suggests you get going and
find him
gadgets and ideas for how you can
upcycle some old fabrics
[Music]
fine is he also gonna make us something
oh i keep forgetting i need to press
this
okay two out of three where the last one
at though
[Music]
wait i have the same one it looks like
underwear
[Music]
he's all for renewal and has even
considered making the trip out into the
wilds to look for a bionuclear spool
and refresh his dna wait you can do that
he can work wonders with pretty much
anything and asks if you know how to
upcycle
the things you make are great so he
makes gear i guess some are and some
aren't
one thing's for sure though your mumma
thinks it all takes up too much space in
the house
he says it's about time you learned how
and offers to teach you
starting with the scrap you found
is that how we got our jeans there it is
okay
uh we can make uh
so many different things
ah tap dish
yeah baby look at that
[Music]
the style might be too edgy for his
taste but he's
sharp on you thank you
i like it i'm anti-fashion okay
at least that way it'll never go out of
style
you should take it with you wear it to
practice but it's an anti-fashion
fashion
i made it so it's mine i'll take it yo
colt
thank you very much he's sure your mumma
will forgive you for not wearing the
traditional outfit oh moma will not be
pleased
forward to seeing what you'll make next
it seems you have a talent for this
[Laughter]
all right teach what the [ __ ] was in
there
wants you to understand that you can do
anything if you work really hard
thanks mom always so supportive eager to
get started
you don't have much time left before the
sun goes down
but there's enough time left for
repetition and you need it
training dummies don't hit back because
they're done
[Music]
you might not be ready to take on
someone with smarts
yet ah don't get weird about moma come
on don't ruin muma
yes
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] yeah i'm getting that bone hammer
back
marking my word
your mumma says you did well today she's
so proud of you thanks moma
thanks you for being such a good student
thanks me
been working on a present for you with
the help of gizmo and whiz
[Music]
you should go see him and find out what
it is you've deserved it
uh all right so i'm edgy right so it's
about time
reminds you that the best way to get
someone to do things
is for you to thank them don't make me
good momma i'm evil oh jesus
lord oh wow oh
oh okay
what am god's earth are you all right
he's
smoking a little item
[Music]
oh there it is i was supposed to catch
it
got him your mumma says she's never seen
an apparatus as green as this little
thing
it's wonderful now you're there
figuring that out is half the fun a
piece of scraptronics like this has
built-in old world tech that makes it a
potent communication device
[Music]
it's called an automaton and it's
hardwired to your dna
what it'll follow wherever you go and
see whatever you see
all right like a blackboard you're lucky
to have such a fine helper with you
[Music]
your muma says you look tired no wonder
it's been a long day but what a day
she's so happy you made the most of it
[Music]
rest and you'll find strength for
tomorrow
that's so cute oh my god they're so ugly
oh my god i made the ugliest character
jesus all right there's uglier from
setting the world
on fire [ __ ] looperlooping stop it
ah loopaloop and i was sleeping
your mumma urges you to blaze a trail
all right how many of you think mumma's
gonna die
but it's raining i'm fine moma
oh rip uh oh i almost [ __ ] that up
fuel to the flames
no problem
you could help me moman thank you
says this is it the time has come she
must fight looper lubin
this time there's no escape she can hear
him coming
this time looper lupin is a problem
older than you [ __ ] looper whatever
happens
you need to know she loves you oh she's
dead
she's done has been to protect f in the
chassis
and though she was chosen to lead
thank you very much cameron she tells
you to stay back this is her fight
it has nothing to do with you history
has finally
caught up oh it's time right back at you
guys by the way
i'll fight with you mama how brave you
are but she can't be worrying about you
while she fights
this is her fight here it comes
the past coming to haunt the present
[Applause]
oh wow are we
sorry i can find i can fight we got this
save mama
i'll get his knees i'll get his ankles
don't worry about it
see i'm i'm doing more damage than mumma
oh i'm almost dead dude we can do it
[ __ ] you looper looper ow
oh i'm dead
calming woman i swim really well
mama you're in deep surf don't make
waves the surf goes where it wants to go
it'll take you to the shore as long as
you go with the flow
we're fine no problem
i'm just gonna let ah [ __ ] loop a
looper
god damn it
just a wee bit closer now
ah [ __ ] loop loop dodge state no
problem
oh we gotta go to movement
are we ditching muma nah
i love puff
oh no no um what you say
mum
is not to be feared by one who has lived
life with a pure heart
a part of her will live on in you
oh moment
the creature is hungry for more nothing
is going to stand in its way now
if a sacrifice is made for someone else
it's not lost
but passed on to the next life
must go on real sacrifice comes from
love and necessity when all other
options are oh geez
the ultimate test of consciousness is
the willingness to give up
anything to save what you truly care
about
this guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ] oh do you
not
oh thanks don't take poopsie do for
yourself
dies with you what you do for your kin
remains and makes you immortal oh
no no no i thought popsicle would make
it for sure
it's like bambi all over again yeah
ah the memories hurt
as the moment fades and is lost the only
thing that remains is loneliness
it doesn't mean you'll forget your past
it simply means you need to move
on [ __ ] you're the one bringing it up
okay now we can craft stuff cool
hold up what can we craft
bone hammer can we get a bone hammer
can i get a bone ham
oh craft nude
uh all right so we can't craft anything
basically
oh modify oh
no no no
all right but we can do it
in desperate looking jews
the tribes caught a fluffy hulk better
watch out their [ __ ]
names
all right a fluffy hack of course of
course
all right i'll take care of the fluffy
hook
weak fluffy
that's not what i wanted to do
let's get his tail
oh midair dude
bang bang whoa
whoa
can't hit this watch this oh
ow
i'm hurt bad
really [ __ ] cool combat
my dude's almost dead there we go
nice it was harder than expected to take
down the fluff
not for me they've received news a ronin
joined the tribe's ranks and were
looking forward to meeting you
go for the names you ain't got no knees
group of jagme warriors are already
waiting for you at myriad's vespidot
outpost you should hurry there and help
them
storm the outpost well show no mercy
mercy is for the weak yeah the jaggery
tribe seek
no one's sympathy nah
all right better not keep the war party
waiting the war
party all right i'm in i mean say no
more let's go hola
did i load him did i load him
oh so fluffy and warm inside
can someone goodbye me goodbye billy
billy
look an emergency box from the update
thanos club
bet that nut makes a tight fist
what'd he do though oh damn a lot of
damage you found the clonk face powerful
tool
punch through walls okay it can be used
as a weapon too you'd give me a quit in
the gear menu
let's equip it right away whoa
what the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] yeah
you're only waiting for me especially
the tag possible special time i prompted
in the low
oh hidden slam
whoa
okay i gotta fill it up going outside
just to see the night sky
mine all day
[Music]
uh-huh which wall though hold up we also
level that
uh-huh oh cool they show you which ones
you have
oh that's the one hidden slime
copper touch okay cool
[Music]
maybe we should unlock this
let's do that for now
[Music]
one more yeah
switcher bends uh-huh
hey actually i want to try this out
hold up let me do this hidden moon it's
like this
i like it
here comes [ __ ] yeah
let's try the melee don't run away from
me there it is
[ __ ] these are strong
[Applause]
getting better at parrying
shouldn't take much whoa
[ __ ] yeah i'm too strong man
level five baby let's go
that was good
oh oh yes
give me a quick hey
oh very cool
nice have we gotta punch through a wall
again
meet the war party
it's is the way
does this game have any pewdiepie skin i
don't know
they made a special build for me and i
it didn't register for some reason i'm
playing an older build unfortunately
reminds me of sly cooper a little bit
yeah
filled with the leftovers of used to be
once
you're getting close to one of those old
toxinol
brick towns pay attention okay
the toxinol corporation made this place
and then just threw it away when they
were done with it there were whole
cities
well small ones places like this were
cheap
back in those days and there was plenty
of space
get done with one place you just build
another
there must be a track somewhere in this
brick town
just hope it's not buried
bricktown i'm in
this corner of the world is called
bricktown
we have to get superb loot and old world
gadget okay
cool oh pp time
vp break very nice
did we level up i don't even realize
uh charisma maybe
as long as you're happy about it
i'm not sure to be honest
oh [ __ ] there's so many
[Music]
air strike i got a lot to learn huh
i can get the shroom you're right thank
you
we're on the dark side somewhat dark
we must cleanse all the light
we have blank but we want fungi
nice thanks chad
to use funky hold the input you have
bound the ability to and release input
to confirm its placement
okay
let's put it on e
mushroom way that's so cool
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
meet the war party am i going this way
oh
fungus peekaboo park landed on it thank
god
love this sort of place
oh [ __ ] enemy
get [ __ ]
yes i knew the fungi would be worth it
come on funky
i thought all right let's just finish
him
yeah the effect tanks are cool i like it
it's like a comic book
oh dude i can't wait to
you get more uh abilities and stuff
that's so cool
all right let's go to the war party we
could a myriad
post oh [ __ ] marriott
hate him
scoundrels
sheesh
whoa that is a lot of damage
[ __ ] i miss
you've already drained
come at me brian
finish him
and that's how it's done
bye
[Laughter]
oh he's still
oh it's the base
i'm waiting for it mushroom
[Applause]
mushroom oh come on
[Music]
look away look away look away wait look
wait nothing happened i did not die i
did not die
no no
okay i pray jesus
hey god damn bridge
ah it breaks my heart i cannot like that
all right we gotta do this again
this is mushroom on the big guy
or to attack the big guy
mushroom it's no he squishes it
oh squish precious mushroom please
please
middle light
now mushroom
save me mushroom
i mix
[ __ ] you monkey
oh what a perfect dodge that's always
done baby
[Music]
mushroom
i'll join you mate
[ __ ] yes
um are there more oh
no no no no yeah get out of here
skedaddle [ __ ]
oh i thought i fell off again
dude the comment is hilarious dude
i love it so good mushroom
come
come on
these are strong
it comes
concussion
hidden slam baby
just hit me maybe i should take out the
arranged ones with melee
you're saved you're welcome live a good
life
nice beanie bro pick your path carefully
by whatever you can see
uh okay says it's a shame that jackni
can't see
what myriad sees a world worth saving
didn't have much else to say so no
problem
it's like real life is relieved you're
not of myriad heritage because you
darken the sky
didn't have much else to say so no
problem
all right i saved your [ __ ] life some
gratitude please
yeah give me that give me that yeah burn
burn i burned it i didn't mean to but i
guess
it comes natural now i'm so i'm so evil
yes oh somewhat dark oh
so evil how evil are you
i'm somewhat dark i dabble
i dabble into the unknown give me
yes
give me uh you found a biocontainment
container collected bioblobs
and use these cell unlock mutations in
the menu or to change your appearance
at biopools tyranny away from that fire
hazard you'll want to wash it
too [ __ ] that's a lie yes you still want
more than that
so it's worth looking around eh
the vespidat long time home of the
myriad tribe
the dead dead
we're playing by mutants in the title
gamers
wake up i love the combat
oh taking piss let's see
uh-huh okay yes
all right let's [ __ ] him up oh wait
these are our friends nevermind
says you need to hit them where it hurts
inflict as much
suffering as possible and make it clear
your tribe is a
terror to their existence bro is their
balls i got it okay
you haven't come here to waste time not
my style
here's the first line of defense [ __ ] em
up
three little sloths they'll make me
laugh
mushroom mushroom tactical
get them when they're down
no not water not water no
don't look away look away look away
there we go what happened
did something happen
do not nine five do nine
all right all right here we are where we
were
[ __ ] up midair baby
oh he's so dead he doesn't even know how
dead he's
hidden slam
hey are they dead
oh it comes
oh bless zero death gameplay feels good
to be a pro
what the [ __ ] is that watch out fellas
i'm trying
ah am i supposed to pick these
up oh i am not the water not the water
hey okay okay
oh no not puzzle can i make it
give those twirly wheels a turn
okay [ __ ] the wrong way
is that it just a few moves left
oh [ __ ] me
so cute oh thank god
big brain i know what do we get
yes yes
[ __ ] you water can't stop me
big brain dessert
most liquid it's time
i know it says cut the chain all right
where's the chain
down in the water down in the drain
boom keep going
yeah it feels a bit fably too there's
like a mix of a lot of games
but it's still very unique
the ultimate bro oh yeah
i agree mr wrap that cage is holding a
helper
oh look at this tyrants how dare they
we would never do that we're good
well that did no damage
yes oh let's get him right in the wall
you're so dead oh i'm so sorry
mushroom
twac [ __ ] yes
oh look oh god that's grim
oh i murdered him
[Music]
oh sweet little soul i thought they
fainted no they fainted
it's kind of a wee bit sexy
you know what i mean free the prisoner
oh yes of course
he's fine he's fine they have prisoners
come on
break
it wasn't me i swear they never lost
hope you'd come but
weren't sure if they'd last long enough
i need you to fight man to carve out
some revenge on those who hurt them
okay good oh
somewhat dark yes
it's getting darker
he looks kind of dead now
that's the pose you make when you don't
want to fight anymore oh
oh what is this oh hello
extermino frog grabs
there equip it
[Music]
what is what
oh a
sharpshooter the scaffolding looks
unstable how to stay clear of the red
ray
okay
red means danger here's the second line
of defense yeah it's three little dudes
get out of here
i thought he said the scaffolding looked
weak
[ __ ] it i'll snipe them
smock and scrunch
he's done oh we level up
nice whoa
do you see that i don't know
oh it even reminds your party animals
you're right what the [ __ ]
okay hold up i love all that uh
agility yeah [ __ ] it max it out
100
mutations blink
[Music]
i should put that on right click
i need a higher level for these okay
what about in general
[Music]
oh that's really good
oh [ __ ] yeah
nah let's save the rest
all right this guy needs to [ __ ] go
my aim is so bad dude
whoa did i get him
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa let's calm
down
mushrooms
i need to get the scaffolding down
make the enemy charge the platform i'm
blind i'm so sorry guys
no blast it
i bet it exploded oh [ __ ]
watch it blue not too close it's
complicated
give it another try i
i get blow up the gate but
rolly rolly rolly rolly roll
oh wow perfect
yeah that's how you roll a barrel right
here thanks for helping me there we go
that should be enough
i guess we're still early in the game
the outpost belongs to your tribe now
yes
it's ours he says you made them weaker
but they won't give up
your sifu thanks you your tribe is
growing
stronger yes of course sifu
always for life
tribe gang that's right
okay hey that should be me i did all the
work
eh that [ __ ]
yes [ __ ] yeah we get the
staff like leonardo each tribe has his
own tribal weapon if you defeat a tribe
you acquire its weapon by helping your
own tribe
acquire weapon you're now allied with
tribe you can decide to switch your
alliance
uh-huh now i'm happy with my alliance
says you did a great job catcher
says he's doing his best to keep up but
from what he can tell
it seems you're making progress with the
tribe conflict
oh yeah he had a feeling you get along
with the jagne tribe
but it remains to be seen what the
future holds for your alliance
you seem to get along with the jag me
trying bro you gotta cut your nails
surprise as you
share an ominous outlook on life don't
say that but
out of date emphasizes that solving the
tribe conflict won't matter
unless you help make a stand against the
world eaters
donatello donatello has to staff i knew
that i knew that
i knew that no no no out of dates
premonitions of imminent disaster are
true
the porky puff needs to be handled
before he says
the time has come to confront the porky
puff at the end of the east route
goop is working on making his goo glide
strong enough to break the waves out to
the world
eater the [ __ ] names
the blue the schmuck pook they're fluffy
uh-huh i will okay let's check it did it
honestly
uh i forgot okay so this is how he's
like
i think the gun was better wasn't it
okay we have the staff it does uh-huh
uh-huh
uh uh uh uh
uh uh-huh
more light means fewer places to hide
yeah hear that
oh we can make a weapon with that okay
cool
we're making that bone hammer give me
more
a hat that's [ __ ] armor
what else we got wrigley's
[Music]
oh
i'm not sure where i'm going but there's
loot
spark plug
we done here visit goop
it's not the name of uh gwyneth
paltrow's
beauty brand
goop
it is isn't it yeah oh
oh oh we can interact
how you doing tells you to find the
ganoate pen
and you'll find knocko and a whole
all right let's put on the hat let's put
on the [ __ ] hat yeah
yes
it's terrible i need to be level eight
and it's worse than my radar taco
damn you can do a lot of stuff uh huh
uh my back nothing
i guess these these are in the crafting
stuff we'll probably get a ton more
stuff like that
[Music]
claims to have strange things from the
dead zone
that are so red
each vendor is specialized on a
particular type of items melee weapons
ranged weapons gear parts clothes and
mounts
mounts going to vendors and browsing
their stock can be a great way to find
better parts for your gear if you're
missing a specific part to craft you can
always check the nearest vendor okay
cool
you can buy and sell oh
bing bad bingo bad
oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh
nippon i want it i want
why am i so poor let's sell some stuff
oh they're not worth anything we can
sell our here a hand
right there are probably more things you
should get rid of
this can add add-ons so it's better
let's keep the hat for now
[Music]
oh we can sell our old weapons
let's sell that
that's a legendary one we want to keep
that let's get rid of this
i can't because it's a quit probably
came out on top i think so
dawn feels like greeting
cypoints
imagines it'll get colder as the tree of
life dies
nice brother to eat then but if you had
a fry sparker to
cook stuff
okay if anyone had the fry spa once you
find it
okay so that's for cooking probably
okay so side quests to get a fry cooker
and this is for gear uh we need to
collect more scent
by then you'll have all the ninja turtle
weapons look at the size of this thing
it's outrageous oh let's go hunting
why that's a good note again
for everyone else they're a perfect
mountain easily
we're getting a mount okay we're not
going to kill him
bush that's nom nom for the good notes
you found a pit plant glide under it
together
pipsy pepsi pipsy
it's my good note yes you can move and
shoot uh
oh i have a canoe oh it's so slow
why goodnotes so slow
eyes on our side sorry
evening fellas you found a rest in place
you can store your
health and key energy or just pass time
okay
you're again majestic you're not again i
mean
we have a new wongfu excuse me
where uh
maybe we should end up where i mean
levitate oh i want that
oh mucus bubble ew well that's so cool
i want that ten [ __ ]
we're just gonna have to keep playing
uh the plague that's ruining the land
let's get our side points
i'm a good no and you judge spin is that
all right let's see
flounders around in there should we
fight some
[ __ ] it we're gonna do kill me i'm an
excellent swimmer
i'm the best swimmer there is
[ __ ] [ __ ] look away
look away nothing happened look away you
didn't see nothing
kiddo
you didn't see nothing oh what's that
that's so weird it went back to the
title
i thought i was swimming pretty well i
don't get caught in a riptide
thank you for the thing no we lost
no i have to run now
uh oh hold up
[Music]
there's my boy yeah
you swim back there's subnautica station
goop flounders around in there oh it's
clearly not in the [ __ ] water
what is that it's huge
oh ho ho
yes secret
oh yes [ __ ] yeah you coming or not
what's all this thing oh it's goop of
course how can i forget goop
ain't the easiest tongue but i think he
says he's happy to see a friendly
face not too many of those around these
days
uh-huh says it's good to see you again
he's goop you might remember him from
the old days when he tried to teach you
how to swim
i do remember group says you were always
so
righteous as a child no no no no
[Music]
says memories fade surprisingly fast
we are all pieces of what we remember
it's only together
he recalls you wouldn't put in the time
required
[Applause]
and protects them until we are ready to
face them again
okay he understands you've returned to
face looper
you've been carrying within yourself all
these years did he just rub it in my
face that my parents drowned
back then didn't vanquish the good in
you that's [ __ ] up
as bright as when you were a child
but he doesn't think you realize how
that'll make you
feel kill him
that's the way no arguing with that
the dark is freeing sometimes your gut
is
flat out wrong don't ever doubt yourself
you
are number one i like this guy knows
you're better than this stick with me
we'll rule the world
says life on the goo is wide open you
have so many choices of where to go
i like the hard way hit the open surfing
the trouble is you can only rely on
yourself at least until you reach a new
shore
and make new friends figures the world
is a goner
even the goo will go gong
they spend too much time nesting to do
anything fun
is already gone it's what you do today
and tomorrow that'll move you forward
you need to set the past aside at least
for now
he can't leave the subnautica station as
the pollution has worn down the
insulation of his suit
so you must salvage enough scrap to fix
up his ghoul glide
starting with the old wreck box outside
you should return when you've retrieved
the scrap
there's no time to waste if you want
you're lucky that way there's still
cargo left on the shores from before
okay we gotta find some scraps around
best guess i know this power tanker hit
a reef and went under
some nautica reference uh somewhat
dark yes oh watch out for the water
enter the sewage tunnel oh gotta take a
peepee
peepee gang
hell yeah
uh what's the saying red sky at night
no that's not right excuse me
red sky at night pp shines so bright
um yeah you um
you know the rest hold up enter this
sewage tunnel where is that here
[Music]
you guys know the reference
oh i don't like this
speed run
okay so
[Music]
oh i thought i was on this one
oh sheesh
just a few moves left
big brain big brain
break through the wall with the crank
fish oh i got oh that's why i couldn't
sell it
did i call it a fish
[Music]
no i don't think it's that one
oh mushroom
[Laughter]
i don't know why it makes me laugh so
much
they're bad against fire
holy [ __ ] i [ __ ] them up damn
the day is cold
it would change your adjacent lines use
the grrrr
oh just a few moves left make them count
uh
i'm very smart i'm very
very very smart as you can tell
thank you
let's find the goop okay i'll take it
ain't nothing brought in here
give me that oh oh
not ready for that
uh brown leather jacket
15 what level am i
not 15 that's for sure god damn okay
make your way through the tunnel excuse
me
making my way through the tunnel
uh huh
i'm not stuck i'm just looking around in
the same area
i'm definitely not stuck
well bloody oh i got it i gotta get him
oh so close dude
oh i saw it
holy [ __ ] i did it i'm so smart
profess brofist
oh that really hurts him huh wake up
wake up wake up
go to sleep oh i'm stuck i'm stuck
oh gg is empty
whoa i tapped out
owies okay
mushroom mushroom
jesus
right between the armies
finish him just finishing there we go
okay i need all the exp i can get
oh nice
we came from there
give that man another mushroom hit him
with a mushroom pity pat
hell yeah that was cool
good guys are bad guys i'm not entirely
sure
right guys nice
a sneak up on them okay maybe not
wow get him with the mushroom
jesus christ you found goog's line part
box
and not now
that's one way to put it
we're cool right mushroom
i should really take out this guy
oh my gosh you're absolutely drained
oh geez louise
come on oh my [ __ ] god
ah this bad mushroom
question
there it is
[Applause]
[Music]
there it is
thank [ __ ] that's how it's done
cute sponge blobby yes nice
is there that smell that yes
more more please i'm gonna upgrade
what on earth
screw boost
[Music]
and
[Music]
mushroom has been the best upgrade not
gonna lie yeah offshore drilling
caused oily matter to spread with the
rain
and contaminate both the groundwater and
open
surf the long-lasting effect this had on
the evolution of wildlife
as we know now the only reason we
came to exist
looks like the switches need to be
turned to match
so enough charge can flow through the
conductor bing
bang bomb
so smart i know you're in shock
good it reminds me of ikea names
the actuators and activate the framework
i agree my name the story has got to
keep moving forward
what up goop did your dirty work you
little gooper
you goober
he's got the goo glide functional you
will have a pull hook and a salvage net
but no armor and an engine strong enough
to break through the thick goo
further out okay but why the pull hook
there's debris floating around on the
surf that might be blocking your path or
needs to be towed
that means you'll need a device so you
can get it out of your way
fair fair goop says gizmos devised a
cannon for the goo glide
but instead of bullets it flips quacks
squeaky distractions for the triple
attentive porky puff
which will give you time to get yourself
in position
the best way to find quacks is to talk
to gulp
he has the bearings of the surfy pelico
and knows where the quacks
this means you'll have the privilege of
visiting gulp in the sinky dink
he'll be able to give you directions to
where you'll find
quacks
despite the fact it makes him birth
goop's not sure if it's the surf
sickness or the radium
syrup that causes it
dude someone with as bad humor as i have
have written that and i love
stinky dink use the normal movement
okay cool we got this now and we're
level seven you can boost speed
of the googs live uh-huh
customize and jump on it and use call
man bun
yeah baby
[ __ ] swimming so cowards let's go
oh yeah the sir i feel it now like
light to brighten your day
strength
he's speaking the language of the gods
the googslide
how many side powers i only have two
side points
turtle form oh i want it
we're only i'm saving for the mucus
bubble look at that [ __ ]
that's just gross i'm not doing that all
right we know what we want
so cool
yes
ask gulp about the gum quacks
did i forget to ask him the horizon
rests on the surfy goo
oh i'm so confused with the names but i
thought
he's goop ass gulp oh gulp
jesus [ __ ] cries
okay
let's go
you're poking around a prime village
oh [ __ ] it let's check it out
[Music]
all right let's see your prices what are
you buying
says the place hasn't worth looking at
it says glue
can i interest you in some i need to be
level 15 to wear that jesus
uh huh
[Music]
what do i get for talking to all these
people let's see
be busy there man says you should take
thanks
okay let's have a wii
how's the game i really like it
it's uh very unique
[Laughter]
says the sifu has ordered a cleansing
fire i'm glad we have a translator on
our side otherwise the surrey would be
from the ashes
the crop is scarce and dry ever since
the plague started haunting the land
so a touch of a torch should be enough
to stop the fire i'm in say no more i'm
on the dark path
he knows they'll understand given enough
time time and discipline are all they
need to adapt to the new world order
you shouldn't concern yourself or worry
about the things you're told to do
be a good soldier the tribe is
unquestionable
did you say pizza i'm
it's only through discipline that you'll
be able to return this land to virgin
ground
and start anew see
on my side go to go
yeah seems pretty clear first instincts
can be
truly awful the fun thing is always the
right thing
next time look at it with a clear heart
darkly dark dark donkey duck dick
hold up i didn't pick the light side did
i
somewhat dark yes we're still dark good
and growing up my beard i feel it
finally coming out
that's good man dark it is
did we have a pits all right let's talk
to the
oh the torch right sorry village
you gotta go this story is as powerful
as you let it be
i appreciate that
why are you gonna stop me from burning
down your village
mushroom
mushroom
can't stop me
mushroom
stand still i'm trying to mushroom you
there we go
weak you are so weak
there's a serenity about this spot it's
a place for rest and recovery
when day can become night no need to
rest for now
whoa that was cool
sorry mate
i'll get sucked mate
here we go
two to five baby
these guys these guys are insanely weak
so strong
hey you are no there you are
three out of five
oh you want to fight
get mushroom
that's the goddamn i'm trying to punch
it suck
yes
point
nice all right one more baby oh loot
dark knight
oh lousy i like the son of a
just like me
if an avatar you'll be a floor bender
you're right
i guess earth bender now i'll be fire
nation come on
let's get real here now they're angry
what did i do
eh what'd i do
mushroom mushroom
mushroom defense too strong
oh he drowned no
get dinged [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah
return to the pirate romanian
okay
fire nation oh that's why i died in
water ah [ __ ] you're right it all makes
sense
and so the tribe's quest for a new world
continues
tonight's ashes will become tomorrow's
wood
your job here is done
you have time to talk until you've given
new orders
show me what you got hey we did our
first side quests
look at us ask golf about the gum
schmacks
sorry village but you know
it looks better now
let's uh let's have a wrist while
there's
i haven't watched korra is it any good
this is still burning nice
okay where's our mount then we should
call on it
you can't spawn transport here
but i need it oh there it is
it came the [ __ ] was it always there
now
that the game what's making that sound
this here is the sinky home of golf
at the very least
[Music]
thinks you've made many angry maybe you
shouldn't be out in the day
i think that's it then
understand you have other places you
need to go
i mind your own bis i think
talk to koopa i will
he's pretty sure he's heard of you
before although the details are maybe a
little hazy
he wonders if you have something for him
to drink
points out that he's hungry too but
always thirsty for more
says you look like you've got a powerful
thirst to do something in this world
good bad not really sure but it seems
like you've been drinking in your
destiny
and liking the flavor you're right about
that i don't know if he could point you
towards something
fun to drink so that you could share
tipster either way he hopes you find a
way to wet your whistle before the world
comes to an awful dry end and leaves us
all
thirsting for more wait your whistle
doesn't that mean something else
[Music]
says life's like a mystery drink
sometimes it's amazing
and sometimes it's awful but either way
don't stop drinking until you're dead
okay
try other drinks sure that's the point
but you can't stop trying new ones or
life gets dull
says you should toast the end of the
world but you'd better hurry
it's coming soon i am
absolutely respect how you take care of
yourself first
instead of trying to swallow too much
[Music]
thinks it's funny you wound up with the
jack knee they drink
so little like birds
maybe they're not thirsty you can't
understand that
everybody's thirsty but who cares about
them
says you'd be as bummed out as him if
you came for the hot stuff
the glug mocker and his favorite
radium syrup that one's even more
intoxicating now
aged in truck tankers and all
without a drink and radium syrup
especially
he can't move much less think as the
power of his mind
is directly proportioned what the
quantity of syrupy sweets
that's why he's called gulp
[Music]
british helps him forget the state the
world is in
but it only lasts until tomorrow the
world is do you have a drinking problem
figures the real problem is finding
something to drink
oh he hey other interests too he's the
surf epelego's self-proclaimed
ornithologist for example
what the hell is that there are other
ways than a cold drink
to relieve i recommend you feel too
impaired at times and
fortunately for you he can help
[Music]
watching pippi's flap is calming better
yet are the ones you can look at and
touch
like quacks squeezing them is a great
way to relax
i've always loved drinking i mean i
don't drink alcohol anymore but like
even just energy drinks
i it just makes anything better like
spending time on your computer having a
drink next to you
just makes it it just makes anything
better i can drink
so much
it's the best it's just the best
okay what i want to know what this means
says he read that in an old world
book it means you're an expert of all
living things that
flap and tweet
no no
has heard the tree of life echoes the
world
the tree might seem strong we'll set
this right
last unless we preserve it the tree will
wither
unless you care for it
says you should take care says i don't
give a [ __ ] step on his town
all right we gotta find the gum hack
i should have peed but we ain't got time
okay
bad weather sorry are we in the right
spot
find the gum hack hollow where
is it down here oh
i'm going to die
am i going today
i found it but how do i get past it
maybe i need my machine
got a jet
what what is happening
oh okay
well where where where where where where
where
where where will you
no no thank you
kill your own two feet ow
jesus
[ __ ] you hentai not happening
not on my way out
i love all that everyone's like it looks
like this game this is excuse me it
looks like i'm cheering them
right oh god different puzzles uh you
need to connect the three cables to the
different ports to solve the
puzzle but they can't go above each
other i see
for the positive negative value these
can be seen above and below the port the
success
connect cable so that they add up to the
amount shown at the box of the screen
switch use as to connect use uh
i'm sorry what so we're at four right
now
why are we at four
we lost one
i am so smart
i am so incredibly smart
you can't beat me
uh chad is crying because they're so
jealous
i understand need a key
damn it where's the king kiaby
i mean i'm sure it's here
get me
oh that's cool we can actually craft
something now
that was luck yeah
someone check if there's something here
it's so sporadic i love it
all right let's call in our mate
oh girl
i don't like these
mushroom more
enough
mushrooms
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh yeah nice that was clean
why are there a bunch of ducks here
you have a chance to change the future
what
why am i doing this
did i make it better
oh another weapon nice
cool what do we get
uh we have so much stuff now
hold up did we actually level up as well
new wong fu uh f
okay i'm gonna do this one that's easier
to remember as well
cool very cool
[Music]
i likey i like e okay okay
oh don't drown oh we need this
oh what oh
oh cool it's random rarity in this
that's awesome
oh what the [ __ ] is it whoa rare nice
what is it
it's a bucket it's an armor can i wear
ah so much stuff
[Music]
they're the same
i found the same [ __ ] yeah because
it's
uh
oh sledgepad i didn't realize we could
have that
oh what oh
yes okay this is
this is our life now
yes more biohazard sweet five
six oh oh dude i can't keep up with all
these items
it doesn't look that cool to be honest
nah jackman tribe
i need to line up the switches so they
match uh-huh
okay that works that works
is that not blurry just a few moves left
fantastic so smart
good that's enough electric current to
initiate the actuators and
activate the framework
i just i want to get more biohazard so i
can get the
whoa i love this weapon okay
uh return to goop
oh i should have pissed down on uh i
mean not on him but
is this goop yeah let's go fast travel
they said you can fast travel do i have
to be at another fast travel spot to
fast travel
what are the rules you cannot fast
travel from here okay
someone has to end this plague before
it's too late
yes i'll do it then
oh we got the key okay nice
nearly there
all right that actually worked holy [ __ ]
oh it's night cool
can we return to goop now
because i'm on a mount i can't faster
hola what's all this resource totem a
monument left behind
by those that picked scrap trying to
keep the area
i like it i like your line uh
it's really fun it makes me want to play
more of it
well what is this what
i can [ __ ] helicopter
combine that with a mushroom and i can
fly higher
than no dum-dum ever done
hold up what was i doing returning to
goob
thank you return to goofy
that's what i do
what up goop give me the latest
save the earth clear the pollution
that's enough quacks to sustain the goo
glide flipper with
infinite ammunition there was five of
them
he was there when the porky puff took
out of dates let's supposed to bash the
totem
peter has made it personal
[Music]
alya thank you nithya chris appreciate
it glad to have you here after that
out of date started using his head
instead of his legs
and came up with the plan on how to best
make a stand against the world eaters
and it wasn't by foot that's how he got
tasked with rebuilding the goo glide
he seems happy to talk
i gotta go understand
you have things hey let's go
lovely yeah
oh we got a journal oh ah goop uh
conquer rival tribes
all right that was that area oh the
little blessed
creation uh
hold up i wanted to
maybe we should go to town and check
some gear stuff
maybe keanu opened yeah cute
we have six and we needed ten right yeah
how are we on the wong fu
darkness makes you miss the light not
really
all right we gotta defeat porky puff
easy
he's quite far isn't he bloody foreign
that's the rival tribe quest that's a
rival tribe quest
sorry where's porcupine maybe we should
go here first
and what's the nearest we can teleport
no the jackass was level 15 we're only
level eight
i'm not sure how we found it so damn
quick
i gotta call him like a note
he's not fast but he tries his best
he's fine he is actually fine
[Music]
mushroom
this weapon
fm oh i should have shot him there
wonderful sound
oh what do we do
i'm flying i didn't do the finisher damn
it
cool
what's all this thing
mushroom mushroom
mushroom
[ __ ] ow
what shoot him
there it is
i don't know what that e-waste was
finished oh god damn it i
[Music]
[Applause]
so cool
oh damn it does a lot of damage
yes
what do we get you should be able to use
that sure
but what is it
hat i love her hat though
so much crazy lit it's amazing easy for
things to hide
down here
how polite to use the door
oh there is loot here oh excellent oh
more shoulder pants can we wear them
right shoulder left shoulder rivet pant
ooh smoothie pad
we have a beanie no
no i'm wearing it i look so sad and
pathetic
i look like a hipster now stop they
no bunny hat funny hat for sure man
[Music]
all right we were supposed to hit these
ah
clean up on that bad
you got a problem with my character's
face how dare you
all right we're getting closer to the
trains
murder mushroom
wrong one there you go
i thought i blocked it
there it is
feeling fierce
the gameplay is so satisfying there's so
much [ __ ] you can do
i don't have enough key do i ah wrong
way
oh no no no no no
[Applause]
you're fresh out of key energy oh
there we go finish that guy out
yes
keep leveling up i like it more points
better [ __ ]
hours stretching before you
[Music]
okay so we're nearby is it that one oh
excellent
[ __ ] them up all of them
it's usually looting these
oh sniper
more stuff please
i like how they have the trenches but no
one's in it
wait i have to approach it from here
[Music]
ah here we go
[Music]
[Music]
this
we go this way
have a good day escape gun
it reminds me of ratchet and clank
just get to it and destroy it i was
sheesh
he's just taking it
yes love it
as i was done yeah i hope it's fun to
watch because i'm
going to [ __ ] people like this every
day
mushroom
[Applause]
so weak
spin swing crack
master shifu taught me the way
all right keep going one more baby
you've been here three hours thanks for
saying it's been fun
ah mushroom him
oh my god stop shooting me he's
squishing my mushroom
whoa what just happened
oh
oh my god
we level up i like that i like that
[Music]
so i have to equip my glove here
[ __ ] you ma level zero needed
what the [ __ ] does that mean
nice work thank you thank you
all right we almost leveled up again
there go the moths toward the outpost
they're good and mad
the outpost belongs to your tribe now
mine ah temple tom pizarros
he says you made them weaker but they
won't give up
bruh just give up who thanks you
your tribe is growing stronger my sifu
i'm loyal to my seafood
avenge mumma i got it
oh he give me a blanket better than
nothing yes
oh that looks sick nice
that's what i'm talking about
thinks your foes will flee before you
can reach them
good ah [ __ ] yeah look at us
started from the bottom we were just a
dumb dumb
now look at us but
all right let's talk to some shop people
wherever they are because i believe we
can craft some [ __ ]
excuse me where how do i see
the difference
come on let me cry are you a craft guy
yes
nope
i want to make something there you are
what does he sell a good note
certificate
what do i do with that i bought it
regret it
what the hell did i buy oh god oh
i didn't even mean to buy this ah
no no i didn't mean to buy you
you're so creepy okay
he's dark that's good dark gnar again
he's ours i guess [ __ ] better get a move
on if you want to change things
[Laughter]
oh how did this happen again
hedler is eager for you you like him
all right let's sell it first right
level 15. oh it's
that's the one we have okay that means
we can sell a lot of stuff now
or keep this no
so
found a good home for your junk
this is actually better
okay
i should have just done this sorry a bit
confusing
all right and then what can we buy
we can buy back all the [ __ ] we had
amazing
whoa oh oh
hey oh
i want this i want that i want that
okay so that's the shopkeeper we need to
make it the crowd
wait then we literally just talked to
you
um level 30.
[ __ ]
who crafts that
okay we'll do that oh god he's so creepy
nice
there you are
what do we have
legends
what are all these parts
um but who crafts them
do i craft them
oh my gosh i craft them
so i can modify this
by changing the oh no that's so cool
okay let's change the stabbies
that's an improvement
oh my god i can't believe i'm finding
this now
we can put this on it
what's the problem level oh it's too
high level
uh okay
level 30.
it looks like we have to level up for
things to get a little bit more fun with
the crafting
what will you make today
feeling slashy
we made something i guess
right
getting jacked hell yeah
uh how are we doing on wong fu
did i not know
we can learn blaze
saved dark aura needed oh
more dark aura light or a light or a
dark aura we get
telekinesis i knew we picked the right
way
i knew it oh god we're riding tight and
don't let go
we're riding him
to the next rival outposts
he's kind of cute
we could build a gun as well should i
try another okay i'm curious what we can
build
how do i select a gun
[Music]
oh i saw it for a second
looks like we don't have that much
that's too high level room for
improvement
okay it's got a scope on it that looks
amazing
oh he's so fluffy
uh the game comes out on 25th of may you
can pre-order it now
i'm playing an older version of it so it
will be even better now all right let's
help these guys
is this sword not as good
[ __ ] hit him there it is
finish him
[Music]
dead
i feel like this is better right yeah
it's much better
oh oh careful now
ah no no
look away
i got [ __ ] there
no one saw it pterodacts
[ __ ]
okay here we go
i i i had the wrong weapon come on come
on
wrong weapon come on
oh my god my my handguns there's more
damage
so many walls have been bought over this
patch of dirt
oh my yeah thank you she's got a sweater
can i show it
marzia has been well i've been streaming
has been knitting a sweater for maya oh
my god that's so
cute look at her swear i might say i
made this just now
do you love it maya
so cute you look so cute maya
oh i pulled it up there you go
[Music]
that's amazing nice and warm
are you nice and warm
[Music]
hello
yes yes yes we can gain more gamers
we can gain more good sunday
feels good man
let's not die this time
my mouth is just standing there
like a [ __ ] tweezer yeah let's get in
the battle with him
[ __ ] you [ __ ] can't reach me
ah
run
this is the way
all right let's see some hold up
hold up ah you said while i was in his
[ __ ] mouth
back on the back on the mount back on
the mount
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
dude i've only done a third i need i
need another strand
no i didn't see my health [ __ ] how tough
are these [ __ ]
damn he's gotta be worth a lot though i
gotta kill him i gotta kill him
i love the mountain
that's funny [ __ ] i'm so bad i'm sorry
i'll get it
i'll get him this time
it's the mount for the dark side
[ __ ]
hold up hold up
this is half the damage but it shoots
way faster
ah what you gonna do now oh [ __ ]
sorry this weapon sucks
[Music]
[Applause]
ow
that's more lacking
oh it does so much damage
no don't kill me don't kill me no he's
so strong
all right you know i'm not i'm not
fighting this guy clearly he's too
strong
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
he's level 12. seems like there's a
whole world of adventure out there but
what if i could beat him
this is a quarrel spot so many walls
that's going to hit me isn't it
ow small we
are we small we maui
[Music]
we're fine
eye on the price
come on 69 let's go
oh i'm stuck
all right third we got a third
[Applause]
oh he gets more lethal are you serious
[Music]
oh we got bigger ones helping us
we can there we can look in there
believe believe
miss this
i'm stuck
oh [ __ ]
come on oh comes
oh
i'm so focused oh
where the [ __ ] is he going then
this is my last chance
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
last part last part last part
is he doing now
that's it that's it that's it that's it
that's it
oh god i'm stuck oh baby
no no i'm stuck i'm stuck no
we're so close to greatness j [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
shut up nightbot shut your goddamn man
you get used to the beasty smell
i hear
[ __ ] your god damn it guys
my face right now
fine fine
i'll do another side quest and level up
a little bit i guess
i wanna kill him so bad he's gonna die
this is a quarrel spot but what if i
can do it
no one's gonna stop me
more dots more dots
more dots
don't get stuck as long as we don't get
stuck we'll be fine
i actually dodged it holy [ __ ] that was
epic
easy
whoa big boy spun from above
have to help so fast dude
oh we hit we got hit we got hit
come on come on come on
let's go
so close so close that close up close
oh baby
he heals
ah no
weak
oh first try live
undefeated champion let's go
i couldn't have done it without you dark
as you know again
[ __ ] yeah let's clean up
let's clean up
thanks chad feels good man it was worth
it after all
[Applause]
[Music]
feels good very good
all right come on come on come on just
die
my teammates do nothing dude there we go
this gun is ridiculous
one more baby
he [ __ ] shot me how dare you
how dare you shoot back
oh sweet xp sweet
sweet is his mind like your mound likes
you well enough
yeah we love each other
[Music]
we're gonna run away together
did he drop anything oh he makes noises
he dropped [ __ ] all
what a [ __ ]
whoo
oh i'm sorry gunner again i have to say
goodbye
i'll be back in her again don't look so
sad
oh okay
bye bye
bye oh oh
[Music]
oh level six don't make me laugh
tribe
[Applause]
getting more used to the combat that's
really fun
okay we found something
what was that what's that goop
hola i forgot about this
sci power right
oh i gotta sneeze i almost said p i also
gotta pee
yeah game is out on all platforms it's
not pc exclusive
you need to be taking care of business
there's the sovereign who runs this
outpost
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you it is
outpost to be invaded
but now that you're working with their
rival he can see why
no i think xbox and playstation sorry uh
well you never stood a chance [ __ ]
he would have preferred if you could
have solved this without violence
at least a peaceful solution has a
chance
while a violent one never has
ah pajama
i have no chance did i just [ __ ]
defeat you
get the [ __ ] out of here
mushroom
unstoppable mushroom whoa this is so
much cooler
how we oh [ __ ] that took a lot hold up
what's all this then
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
almost there
that's always done nice tongue bruh
level 10 outpost belongs to your tribe
now
mine welcome to the club perv
oh papa little he says you made them
weaker
but they won't give up your sifu
thanks you your tribe is growing
stronger
and i'm getting more eviler
apple shops are now open so we
oh jami jura it's wearing pajamas nice
i didn't notice
[Music]
thinks you did a great job capturing the
rival let's finish then
says they won't that's true well i don't
get an item this time
huh huh it's my [ __ ] item
and to the fort
i sound evil when i say evil ear there's
nothing more evil
than the eviliest of me energy nice
i should start using this
thank you hold up
nice hat i like my armor though thank
you very much
yeah i hope you overthrow the leader at
the end that'd be fun
get some more parts
thank you thank you i'm sure they'll
come to great great great use
time to make a deal
rare i wanted this samurai sword
not a [ __ ] wrench there it is the
safe no wait
the woo
i'll buy it [ __ ] it
there's a hammer again
oh
you got the best of that i did
now we can make
very cool
you have all the bits you need i
do indeed you're too low on scrap
i need what one wood and one ring
i can buy that wonder what's all the way
out there at the edge of the surface
two-handed weapon
all right it's gotta go all right it's
gotta go
jesus christ
oh
what is this boom bonk
oh man i have so much stuff that i can't
use in forever
fair trade
okay let's just use this for now
we also leveled up
string out those guns thank you
all right you know what [ __ ] it let's
get this the evil one
let's get this one you have an
yeah is it dinner time okay
that can only mean one thing gamers it's
time to end the stream
guys if you're interested in the game
link in the description pre-order i
recommend it it's cool
i had a lot of fun i hope you guys had
fun too thanks for joining me
happy sunday happy times
thanks very much for sponsoring the
stream highly recommended very epic
link in dubu also remember i played an
older version so
it'll be even happier
dinner time
all the best gamers hit it here
bye bye bye bye
[Music]